[rock music]
- Hey, everybody,
I'm Tommy Matthews
with Crooked River Forge.
Welcome to my space.
♪ ♪
So this is where my forge is.
This is where all
my heat magic happens.
My forge is pretty much,
you know, old-school.
I don't have
any fancy equipment,
no power hammers, no presses.
It's all done by hammer.
♪ ♪
And here we have where
the rest of my magic happens.
I do a lot of my handle work,
the grinding.
Pretty much fit and finish
happens in this room here.
♪ ♪
So I had a little problem
with my heat treat oven
this morning.
It wasn't getting
up to temperature.
So I had to go source
a new one
and ran out and bought that
this morning
before I came into the shop.
So...whoo-hoo!
♪ ♪
- Hi, my name is Mike Gould.
This is my happy place.
I'm in armor, which was fun
being on the show,
because it's totally outside
of my area of expertise.
♪ ♪
I have some old machines
I've built in here in the past.
This was a plasma cutter.
I really can't claim that I
completely designed the thing.
It was from a kit.
And the thing about it is,
I used to be a big-time gamer
till I found out
I could make computers
move stuff around.
Then everything changed.
I use a mix of technology.
I have a bunch of hammers.
I have different stakes.
I found, with a blacksmith,
guy can get by with
three hammers, armor.
We require a variety,
a fairly large variety.
♪ ♪
- This is our amazing man cave.
So whenever we want
to take breaks and whatnot,
this is where we come
to hang out,
watch movies,
play a little drums,
some pool.
So the man cave also doubles
as a showroom
for all of the work
that we do here,
so here's my little space
of my wares.
The stuff that I sell the most
are what I call
Western French Chef.
Very, very sleek,
very--very well-balanced,
very fast,
good rocking.
This was a leaf spring
that was turned into
a competition chopper.
So we feel like we've got
the coolest man cave
maybe ever.
♪ ♪
- I recycle a lot of material.
This is a charcoal/coal forge
that started out life
as a beauty salon sink.
♪ ♪
This started out as my 1x42.
So I had all these 1x42 belts.
Well, once my original
belt sander went belly up,
I went ahead and took
an old treadmill
that somebody had retired
to the side of the road
and converted it
into a belt grinder.
It's kind of a useful
little tool,
but it literally
is a collection of junk.
♪ ♪
This is my happy place.
Thanks for coming by
for a visit.
You know, I love sharing
what I do.
♪ ♪